foreign thank you very much Allison it's
a pleasure to be here yes I've looked up
uh to Allison for
um basically my entire adult life and so
it's absolutely a dream come true to
come here and share my research with all
of you
I am the pi and director of the
cognitive optimization relational
robotics laboratory at Georgia Tech
where we are trying to enable robots to
work in the hands of everyday end users
relaxing a lot of the assumptions we
make about those interactions so we can
really automate the job of the
roboticists so to get myself out of the
end user robot Loop
why might we want to do that
here's a graphic we're on the horizontal
axis you're going to see years where
we're actually very much towards the far
right of this graph
and the vertical axis on the left you're
going to see the number of full-time
equivalents of registered nurses
and on the right the average age of the
population
in the United States
unfortunately what we find is that the
minimum standards for a government
agency hsri Supply requirements for
nursing is outstripping the availability
of nurses
that's the minimum standards that's not
actually what we really need to take
care of everyone if you look at this
graphic for example out of North
Carolina
we are already approaching this linear
decline that's going to go on in
perpetuity unless something changes so
we're going to have a drastically
insufficient number of healthcare
professionals to take care of our aging
population not only are older people
requiring more care intervention
but also that means that there are fewer
young people who can also be in the
population to take care of them
we are working as a part of the AI
caring Institute NSF funded at Georges
HACC the program director was is Sonia
chernova
and we're working with the cognitive
empowerment program at Emory University
to look at how we might be able to use
technology deploy robots or smart smart
home technology to enable
the individuals with mild cognitive
impairment who ultimately might have
dementia
to stay in their home as long as
possible
to have some autonomy some dignity
before they might have to go to an acute
care facility
these individuals slowly lose their
capabilities and Retreat from society in
a very sad way and we just don't have
the resources to take care of them and
so our long-term goal is to actually
have these robots be able to be deployed
by Care Partners adult children or
spouses who are still fully cognitively
intact who could help program these
robots to perform everything from taking
out the trash to delivering proper
medicine to actually developing models
of your behavior so that they could
identify if you might have had a stroke
or have some other decline that might
warrant and benefit from medical
intervention
the challenges are also in manufacturing
with our aging population unfortunately
the US is slipping and our manufacturing
output and that our population and the
skill set that we have is not keeping up
and we need robotic systems that are
going to enable our work in cyber
manufacturing which I recently have a
grant on with some of my colleagues at
Georgia Tech and kind of focusing
American manufacturing on made to order
custom parts that can be efficiently
cheaply made for you unfortunately most
of that work has to be done manually now
because it's one-offs but if we can
actually have general purpose robotic
systems that can learn and adapt on the
fly without needing somebody in C plus
plus to come
and rewrite the robot software every
time a part changes then maybe we would
able to be to realize this kind of
made-to-order cyber manufacturing future
so how are we going to do this how are
we going to have robots actually
deployed in Mass around the world
um are we going to have hand-derived
controllers as one of my colleagues
Professor Seth Hutchinson likes to say
why don't I just pay one of my grad
students to do it why do you actually
need your reinforcement learning
algorithms
um well I don't think there's enough
grad students to go around solving every
problem that robots are going to have in
the future
it's also very challenging we've evolved
over tens of thousands of years to be
very amazing at performing a great
variety of tasks to close a loop between
perception decision making and action
and we often find it difficult to
articulate that into a program that
would enable a robot to work that's why
for example we use deep neural networks
for computer vision rather than a
decision tree
we could also just think about pure
reinforcement learning
we have tried that we've tried arm farms
and they have had some impressive
successes
But ultimately the amount of resources
that you need to invest into
reinforcement learning because it's a
lack of sample efficiency how long it
takes to learn it and just for a very
single task with a very clearly defined
and perhaps shaped reward function
that's also not really a scalable
approach so I argue we need to bring and
leverage bring the human into Loop
Leverage What humans are good at being
able to quickly learn adapt create teach
disseminate knowledge
and enable the right robot techniques
the right formulations of artificial
intelligence and machine learning and
explainable AI so that these systems can
collaborate with you and you can
customize their behavior for whatever
application you need
what am I specifically saying when I
talk about learning from humans
let's say learning from demonstration
lfd is going to take his input a markup
decision process without a known reward
function we're going to have a set of
states of the world say in a healthcare
environment we can describe the state of
the world as where all the patients are
and obsectious and Gynecology we can
describe their gestational age how many
children they've delivered before if
they've had any kind of anesthetic
applied or other medications or
comorbidities
it's really kind of a pomdy p but we're
going to ignore that for a moment
we can have actions if you're a charge
nurse and this is at the Brigham and
Women's Hospital in Boston Massachusetts
this single charge nurse has to
basically be an air traffic controller
deciding which of something the order of
30 nurses in scrub techs are going to
have to take care of which patients when
where and Route everyone through so that
everyone in all the mothers delivering
have the right resources at the right
time so that nothing goes wrong and she
currently doesn't have any decision
support and they're literally using a
whiteboard with rows and columns where
people write in the information and
update it as you go
so she can make those decisions about uh
Resource Management who should take care
of what when where and how
and we want to learn from her
her policy Pi star that's going to map
the state of the world to the action
that she would take for managing these
resources in labor delivery and minimize
a measure of Divergence or difference
between what the robot would guess the
human would do PI of s and then what the
human Pi star of s would do and then
whether we take the expectation over the
distribution of States induced by the
teacher versus the learner gets us
whether we're talking about Behavior
cloning or imitation learning if you're
familiar with those Concepts and so and
so in my prior work we actually did this
to provide decision support for nurses
now why would I want decision support
for nurses well it's an incredibly
stressful job and as I'll show you later
their decision making is actually
impacted by a workload
their decision making might deteriorate
and high workload high stress situations
so if you can actually learn from
experts in nominal conditions perhaps
you could provide decision support for
them or play Devil's Advocate role when
things get more stressful there's also a
lot of work by Maya matarich that I
would point you to for why we want
something embodied ultimately I want
this robot to be physically useful as
well but in the meantime there's
actually a lot of cognitive benefits and
the psychosocial aspects of trust
Reliance and compliance on this
technology that can be that we can
modulate through an actual embodied an
anthropomorphic form
so why should all researchers care about
learning from demonstration let's just
do it RL
well first many great feats of
reinforcement learning are precipitated
because of learning from humans the
original alphago relied on a backbone of
supervised learning to get it to work
and there's actually one sentence in
that paper if you go and read it that
says why this might be the case that
human we needed to use a human
supervised learning model as the
backbone instead of our early said maybe
something about humans can explore the
space better
it's just like one sentence on it
um of course they had RL built on top of
it and then ultimately they solved it
without the need of humans
um recently there's gato that came out
as pure supervised learning maybe in a
few years once we've now kind of figured
out how to do this with imitation
learning maybe one day we'll figure out
how to do it with RL from scratch
second lfd can be used to distill
engineering controllers for
bootstrapping RL so Byron boots panels
Co trust and evangelist theodoro have
been doing a lot of work where you can
actually design NPC controllers or other
mechanisms from from control theory and
actually have a neural network imitate
the controller and then do RL on top of
that to exceed the ability of the
engineer to hand specify a controller
it's pretty cool idea
and then thirdly work
um with Peter Beale on contragon has
looked at
say digital cooking environments in
which a human and an AI would work
together to coordinate activities to
bake items
and you can actually think about the
challenge that would be to train an RL
agent from scratch with a human I don't
know if anyone in this room would live
long enough to provide all the samples
needed for an RL agent to learn
something complicated but what if you
could have two people playing together
and you could learn with imitation
learning a model of that human and used
in basically in a dream state offline of
an RL agent work an infinite amount of
time with that model of a human and then
be able to deploy that RL agents in the
real world they've shown some promise
for that
and why not because humans are amazing
we should want to learn from them we can
jump from space we can separate
conjoined twins without ever having done
that before that specific case of
conjoined twins and we can fly like Iron
Man almost
but humans also have failings we have
biases so this video is not fake
but you've probably never seen it before
and this is not just people trying to
make fun of astronauts or create a hoax
for the moon landing the moon landing
really did happen I was there
um so you have a Gravity Sensor in your
head the otolith organs will tell you
where down is it can actually get messed
up when you are in high G situations it
used to be that Pilots launching off of
aircraft carriers would when they're
thrown back from the g-forces their
otolith organ would slide to the back of
their head and they would think that
they're looking up and the right off
they go to the carrier they pitch the
nose down and fly right into the ocean
so they had to change the rules and
you'll see videos of the Pilots Holding
On To A handlebar up in their cockpit
they're not allowed to touch their
joystick until they actually get
airborne because of that and when you're
on the moon the gravity is so small your
otolith organ doesn't work right so
you're only working on your visual
system and if you're walking on the side
of a hill your eyes tell your brain that
you are sideways and you need to orient
yourself perpendicular to the surface of
the hill and then there's just enough
gravity that you will fall over
and your brain can't figure it out so
it's pretty funny but we still went to
the moon and the astronauts still
figured out how to get around enough I
think they even maybe hit a golf ball
so there are these limitations
physically
there's also cognitive biases that we
have
um many of us have probably experienced
that algorithm or that paper we just
can't figure out and it's a sunken cost
fallacy but we just we have to get it to
work there's no way I spent this much
time on this paper to fail
there's confirmation bias that we often
experience when we want to try to see if
we're right or wrong about an idea that
we have and these operation you know I
know that Professor dorsa city has also
looked at these issues that bounded
rationality that limit and actually
benefit us in living in this world
but I think a lot of machine learning
researchers want to just think of humans
as spherical just like physicists joke
about the spherical cow
and I'd also say that a lot of people
perhaps in the machine Learning
Community because we need so many
samples for these models to work we're
just going to farm it out on mturk or
prolific which we do that research too
because we need lots of data
but I think we forget that humans aren't
just these soulless mindless automata or
in this case necrons if anyone knows
what this is come talk to me afterwards
um yes good
they sold their souls to be able to you
know
do well
so we're not this
and when researchers treat us like that
this is what happens
you end up with a guy wanting to watch
Winnie the Pooh and his Tesla and not
pay attention and he dies
you have aircraft autopilot systems that
are so complex and unfortunately brittle
and misunderstand the state of the world
that people die
we have NASA rover planners who still
reject the decision-making of autonomous
planners when it comes to science
activities on Mars they will allow these
systems to kind of have fun when nothing
matters but when you actually need to
drive up to a science Target and do real
science on Mars that's still done by
humans
and then surgeons are notorious for
rejecting systems developed by Engineers
who are trying to help but we end up
solving the wrong problems and I argue
that autonomy fails to live up to its
potential because researchers fail to
understand the human and human autonomy
interaction
so in my vision I want robots to be able
to deployed in this case we did work
with Boeing for manufacturing their
triple seven and National Security
environments in healthcare and in
exploring space I want us to have an
R2D2
there's no roboticist there fixing the
Ross node in the back end there Luke and
R2D2 are working together they
understand each other they develop
shared mental models can anticipate each
other's needs and not have to
communicate everything to each other
so we're going to do this in my lab by
first giving robots insights into human
decision making through learning from
demonstration and human subject
experiments we're going to then close
that Loop through explainable artificial
intelligence to enable humans to
understand what the robot has learned or
and even teach the human how to be a
better teacher of robots
and then we want to scale it up to
coordinate a reasoning of heterogeneous
teams of humans and machines because not
all humans are alike we need to account
for the
inherent weaknesses and strengths of
each individual member of a team I'm
going to focus today on the closed loop
though
and think about why again do we need
imitation learning why can't I just ask
an expert how do you be an amazing
fighter pilot I'm going to write all
that down and then put in a drone and
then I have my fighter pilot in a box
that doesn't work because experts can
give you what they think but not how
they think about it and actually the
worst thing you could ever do to an
expert while they're doing something is
ask them how are you doing what you're
doing
so if you're ever going to do a tandem
jump and the person's doing their
checklist to keep you safe don't
interrupt them
there was a a really good article by
Bella chatal in 2008 I looked at expert
chess players set them up to win a
Checkmate in a three move sequence but
they changed something about the board
said that three move sequence wouldn't
work anymore
and you need to find a four or five move
sequence and they said find it and think
out loud as you're doing it the experts
would say that I'm searching for novel
options all across the board but if you
actually watch their eyes their eyes
were looking at the same three move
sequence over and over again
there was a disconnect between what they
thought they were doing and what they
were actually doing
there's also the Einstein effect it's
roughly German for habit that experts
part of what makes you good is that you
commit to muscle memory and habituate
your decision making and you have a hard
time thinking outside of the box
so I've seen this firsthand and and
decision making of nurses working with
Julie Schott MIT Neil Shaw and Tony
Golan the Beth Israel Deaconess Medical
Center and our work to playing a robot
there the nurses decision making is a
function of patience the number of
patients in the the labor and delivery
floor at least in our gaming environment
we didn't actually close the loop on
robot we didn't execute the robot
actions in the Real Environment we just
offered suggestions so we developed a
game to explore this and that for every
additional patient in awaiting religious
progression showed us that we had a 47
increased chance of a nurse recommending
that a patient a mother of an expecting
mother go out for dinner and come back
later
um that's an okay thing because it's not
fun to hang out in hospital forever but
should that really be a function of the
nurse's workload
maybe not
more frankly it's clear that increasing
workload on labor and delivery x-axis
the number of patients in the waiting
room that the nurse has to triage
results in increased delays for patients
transferring off the waiting room
transferring off the floor starting
their C-section and getting triaged
and so we can't just think of humans as
as these spherical cows that are
invariant to everything
humans do often provide sub-optimal
demonstrations adopting heuristics
because of the complexities of life
and much of lfd work still makes strong
assumptions on the demonstration
optimality that humans are always giving
you the perfect State action pair that
the robot just needs to imitate
and there's been a lot of great work and
preference-based reinforcement learning
I'd say that dorsa is probably the the
world leader in that topic at the moment
um
and so it's awesome to be here and and
also scary to say this in front of you
requires soliciting an abundance of
human preferences over trajectories a
high cost and there's an error prone
process although dorsal work has done a
lot to make that much more sample
efficient as well
and so I'm going to introduce something
called the noise performance
relationship which came out of Scott
nikum and Daniel Brown working together
on something called T-Rex yes like the
dinosaur
and let's look at the half cheetah
domain it's a 2d plane where this half
cheetah thing tries to run as fast as
possible
let's add so mix to the robot's policy
Pi some amount Ada of noise to all of
its joints so it kind of Shakes as it
moves and with this uniform distribution
and so we're going to have a state
action trajectory with some noise added
to that Tuple
and the more noise we add the worse the
OS Behavior gets but how much worse is
it actually getting
well because there's a built-in reward
function for this we can actually
compute that reward get an actual number
for it and then plot it on this axis and
see that it's something like the right
hand side of a sigmoid maybe it's an
exponential decay
well what's interesting is that if we
could figure out the relationship
between the amount of noise that we add
to a robot's execution of a policy if
that's our Behavior cloning version of
what we learn from a human or somewhere
along here then maybe we could
extrapolate what negative noise kind of
might look like even though that doesn't
really make any sense that's kind of
what we're going to do and so prior work
uh d-rex
looked at automatically generating rank
trajectories through this noise
performance relationship so first doing
imitation learning and then adding doing
rollouts and adding increasing amounts
of noise and then using a loose Shepherd
rule to end up figuring out how to I you
know figure out some interval ranking or
ordinal ranking to these trajectories
there's a couple of drawbacks that use
Behavior cloning which does suffer from
covariate shift and although
it is a very highly practical
mode of learning where it's just it
simply supervised learning so we learn a
policy to map states to actions and I
think I heard from somebody that we're
now going to have a paper maybe already
exist called all you need is behavior
cloning uh there's like all you need is
diversity all you need is attention
maybe there's all you need is behavior
cloning
the other issue is that the Lou Shepard
rule also is not quite adaptive to the
individual domain or task that you're
trying to learn and that if you set it
up with three specific trajectories and
you try to figure out what the reward
would be you would find that it should
be like the geometric mean of the two
around it in this case and so it's
generally homogeneous across the tasks
and so we want to learn some way to
characterize this noise performance
relationship that is responsive to the
specific algorithm that's being learned
learning on in the task at hand and so
we tried to characterize this in a coral
paper this was by one of my students
late Tian Chen we looked at a number of
open AI gym environments Mountain car
pendulum Etc and on the x-axis the
amount of noise you have and the y-axis
is a normalized amount of the reward
that you would accrue when you have an
a2c reinforcement learning algorithm
trained to optimality and we're just
going to degrade it and see how much
worse it gets as you add noise to the
rollouts we'll do this for PPO and
software director critic and we found
that it's not homogeneous there's
actually it's a function of the RL
algorithm so the style of the execution
and also the specific task at hand and
if you fit the Lou Shepard rule it
doesn't have the capacity to to
appreciate this
and so instead if you fit a sigmoid to
the actual data points you can capture a
lot of you can explain a lot of the
variance with just a few parameters of
the sigmoid so that's what we're going
to exploit so we're going to start with
an adversarial inverse reinforcement
learning setup we're going to take
demonstrations from the human a set of
trajectories which are a sequence of
State action pairs for how a robot is
going to perform the Tasker in this case
the human's doing it and then we're
going to try to learn a policy that
takes the same States from those demos
or its own States predicts the action
the human would take and then we're
going to compare the synthetic action
versus the real action through a
discriminator that has within it
um an estimate of the reward function
that it learns to predict if it's coming
from the human real or if it's coming
from the robot fake
once we've learned the reward function
we can extract the reward function out
of the discriminator itself and we get
the policy we now have this should now
be able to pair it what the human did
and this should be able to guess how
good it was
as a function of the trajectory of the
specific rollout and so we're going to
add noise to a number of rollouts of
this policy we have to pair at the
person thinking that the more noise we
add it should get worse and then we're
going to get the reward function we
learned to give us an initial guess for
what the the quality of that
demonstration the robot's Behavior was
when you add a certain amount of noise
to it
that will give us the scatter plot we'll
then regress in a sigmoid function to it
and then we're going to go back and
force the reward function to then fit
the sigmoid so the sigmoid here is
basically going to act like a low pass
filter or a way to help us distill
something that generalizes the reward
function better from the person so we
can ask the robot what is better than
what the human showed with ever without
ever having to ask the human what is
better
we also try to improve the robustness of
our initial reward that we're learning
because we're adding all of these noisy
trajectories those are very different
than what the human demonstrated and if
we overfit or discriminator or reward
function to think about these noisy
trajectories that might induce this
misalignment of what we actually care
about and so we're going to do this kind
of importance resampling where we kind
of flip the importance of the likelihood
that the human took it measure that
relative to the likelihood that will get
it from a noisy policy to make sure that
we have the expectation over over what
we care about
We compare this to d-rex so the full
d-rex algorithm is on the far right
using Behavior cloning with the Lou
Shepard rule for Learning and then we
use noisy ARL with self-supervised
reward regression and across a number of
simulated domains we are able to find a
high correlation between the ground
truth reward function which the
environment has built in and then what
we are able to infer and that both as an
ablation the noisy a IRL component does
better in airl which does better than
Behavior cloning and this is the reward
function that we learned
and that you can see in blue here those
are the synthetic trajectories that
we're able to learn from that we create
blue or hold out data points that are
testing and then red is the single
example that we learn from the person
and so we're able to improve over prior
work particularly in that change from
the blue to the green dots for for
generalization
and then if you have the reward function
now we can actually synthesize a
controller a reinforcement learning
controller against that to outperform
the initial demonstration quality that
we got
we deployed this in a table tennis
because it's fun and it's easier than
real tennis
and we looked at metrics for our
demonstration of the the lateral speed
how far the ball how fast the ball is
moving down this way how fast this would
be falling after it goes down the net
which is a proxy for topspin and then
the estimated reward we get from
self-supervised reward regression and
then we compare that to ARL which should
basically just mimic what the person did
and then self-simprovise reward
regression was able to learn to hit the
ball faster with more spin without ever
having to ask in this case Rohan palacea
how to what better was it automatically
figured that out so that's really
exciting for us I'll note that I have a
rule in my lab that all the students
should be wearing shoes he's not
I don't condone uh being Barefoot around
robots
but maybe Sawyer is not so bad
all right
we can do more though to characterize
specifically an individual person's
sub-optimality and there's another
flavor of learning from demonstration
algorithms known as dagger which has you
teach the robot while the robot is
trying to perform the task
so we're going to imagine a car driving
itself and you're sitting in the past in
the front driver's seat and you're
trying to steer the robot to go in the
right direction but the robot basically
ignores you until after it's over and
then it learns from all the feedback
that you gave it as you're trying to
fight it that's kind of a difficult way
to learn from and so researchers have
said you know Behavior cloning is all
you need maybe it's easier but dagger is
really nice because it kind of gets up
alleviates this covariate shift issue
and has more nice statistical properties
for for that learning so you're
basically learning from uh you're
learning Corrections from mistakes uh
which which is a kind of a nice
mathematical framework but it doesn't
really set up people well to provide the
demonstrations
so people are sub-optimal here well what
if we could characterize how the person
is suboptimal and then add that whatever
that error is in this case perhaps the
person over or under corrects or is
anticipatory or delayed in their
feedback while they're trying to steer
the car to teach the car how to drive
through an obstacle course
if we can characterize how they're wrong
then maybe we can fix that on their
demonstrations for a new task and then
better provide training data for dagger
to learn the desired task and so if we
assume we have a set of calibration
tasks we have the ground truth optimal
trajectory where the robot should go
we can then have the person give their
corrective feedback for the robot
sub-optimally performing that task as
though it's still trying to learn we can
measure how off the person is from what
the optimal feedback should have been
within uh we use variational inference
for for Mutual information maximization
between an embedding and the person's
actions to to capture that kind of
characterization of the person's
sub-optimality and we developed an
approach mind meld I'm a huge Star Trek
nerd live long and prosper
and within this embedding space we can
actually see over correctors who are
delayed over correctors who are
anticipatory kind of characterized by
these uh the colors and then the
magnitude of it is the size of of those
colors and then we can kind of learn to
rank them in their quartiles for how how
poor their feedback is and we actually
showed in a recent paper that came out
in HRI 2022 this year that Mariah Shrum
and Aaron Hedland
show that we could improve the data that
we give to dagger to learn from so that
dagger now actually learns better than
either vanilla dagger or behavior
cloning by learning to basically correct
for the human's feedback on a novel task
I said that I was going to close the
loop
it's not just humans teaching robots or
even robots characterizing human
teaching but now we want to actually
make humans better teachers
and Mariah and Aaron continued this work
in a paper that they're going to now
present to New Zealand so I'm very happy
for them to get to go fight some some
urukai there that in our first study so
this was the same mind Mill set up where
you're teaching a car to drive through
an obstacle course we're going to
characterize their sub-optimality and
then we're going to in that embedding
space if we annotate it so we we
actually have to give it semantically
meaningful dimensions in this embedding
space that's our our limitation we tell
them hey you're actually over correcting
maybe do less of that
um and we modulate that by how
significant they're they're over under
correcting and their temporal offset is
and we showed first that we can modify
your behavior and how you teach the
robot so we can kind of induce you to
move around in this sub-optimal
embedding space
second we looked at is it best to tell
people all the ways in which they're
wrong or just pick the worst way
and and characterize kind of design from
a user's perspective it's actually
useful to give people multiple uh
to actually tell people all the way in
which they're wrong but I know that
sounds horrible to say out loud uh but
that that is a useful thing to think
about and then finally is it actually
going to make people better in the long
run so if we don't have calibration
tasks now because we've made people
change their behavior because we
provided feedback
through multiple rounds of training the
human to be a better teacher on a novel
task where the robot doesn't know what
the ground truth is
and I've changed the person's Behavior
can I use a neural network that's
specifically an lstm architecture to
predict
where you should now be in this
embedding space hopefully it's near
optimal but I don't know maybe you've
wandered off in the wrong direction can
I figure out where you are now because
of my impact on you as a robot teaching
you as a human
and still correct for your
sub-optimality now and provide a better
training signal for dagger
and we showed that yes in fact we can
still figure out how we are changing
People well enough to be able to
characterize them and close this Loop
and improve the human machine team
um I also like to have my students not
just try to make people better but try
to make people worse because there's an
important confound when you're looking
at adaptive systems that you need an
Adaptive Baseline
and what better than back to adapt to
Baseline than actually showing you can
control people in every Dimension this
is another kind of issue with running
actual human-centered experiments so we
can actually make you better or worse on
the feedback you give
I want to start bridging now to think
about more complex setups than these
low-level skills for short-term
trajectories and some of our work that
came out of Andrew Silva looked at now
how do we bring in language to learn
from different tasks where prior work up
until very recently most people have
been looking at multitask settings where
robots are going to do table time
manipulation tasks opening closing
windows open closing drawers maybe
picking up balls pick up in place
objects so we have a variety of tasks
within metal World developed Chelsea
Finn and peterbil and others were
working on that developed mt10 and then
mt50
and we had this idea maybe you know all
the great work that's being done in NLP
and starting to look at multitask
learning maybe we can start doing that
with learning from demonstration and so
uh there was contemporary work that was
looking at this idea of using a language
to specify the task instead of using one
hot encoding of the different tasks you
want to do
we in contemporary we showed that and we
also extended to the imitation learning
case so that we can have people provide
natural language and demonstrations to
be able to in a more sample efficient
way generalized to show new behaviors
and more quickly learn synthesize robot
control policies for new behaviors just
being Guided by language
there is kind of an issue though when we
work with large language models as many
of you know that there are
sometimes toxic contents in the data
sets themselves and the models learn on
that and then the contents can kind of
get a bit squirrely you all maybe
remember Microsoft hey
and some other info no but no shaking of
the head okay I'm getting older already
so there are issues and so we I was
working with Andrew hunts and some other
researchers at the University of
Washington that looked at the kind of
the impact of when large language models
meet robots that there might be some
important Downstream impacts of that
that might have unintended consequences
so it's not a focus to my talk but I'd
refer you to our recent paper of fact if
you want to learn more and I'm happy to
talk to you about it offline
ultimately I want these systems deployed
in the real world whether it's in
somebody's home or in a manufacturing
environment this is a picture of C-130
we had a project with Lockheed Martin
we're looking at drilling riveting
fastening sections of their C-130
fuselage
and they have a lot of non-recurring
engineering effort and made to order
customizations that they might need to
consider particularly on Commercial
manufacturing and so we looked at how
robots could be taught by individual
workers on the shop floor to
without a cad model of the part develop
such a virtual representation and then
learn within that representation the
skill set and modeling of the skills
that the human wants the robot to
perform often you have humans that are
very skilled running around from
fuselage to fuselage doing just these
random odds and ends with each aircraft
because the scale of it cannot justify
spending in order to immense amount of
money to develop actual robotic
Solutions in the way we think about it
for automotive manufacturing and so we
can buy an imitation and reinforcement
learning here to be able to do this it's
it's actually really hard to put a peg
in a hole with tight tolerances
and as we build to multitasks and now
multi-step tasks
and our robots are going to be in the
home and actually try to cook you a meal
we're going to have to really think
hierarchically and efficiently because
we don't want to teach you teach Roba
how to cook a meal by showing the entire
meal and say this is everything you need
to cook French toast no I wanted to
learn how to crack an egg I wanted to
learn how to get the egg out of the
fridge or a general object out of the
fridge and then reuse those skills in a
recipe
so that I can compose it for arbitrary
new skills in the future that's also
that's going to make learning easier and
it's going to make the burden on me less
significant as well
for us to help people learn these novel
tasks we're going to have to develop
learning from demonstration approaches
that can handle long Horizon multimodal
multi-task specifications that generally
Falls within the the vein of task and
motion planning we're at the low level
we have these kind of Keto Dynamic
planning elements and then we might have
like PDL like structure shifts planning
it's something at a hierarchical level
we have hierarchical task networks and
we wanted to know can people teach
robots with Tamp recipes
so I think a lot of people thought yes
there was an important work looking at
Key frames by egg gun with my chalk mock
about 10 years ago that keyframes is
kind of the idea that you could have if
a robot's going to pick up a cup off of
a table you could show like the basic
key like waypoints along that trajectory
the what we're going to find though is
that in in many of those setups the
humans are trained on how to provide the
keyframes for the distribution of tasks
that they're looking at so then humans
can kind of just parrot what they
literally saw can humans actually
generalize that to a different task to
break it down in some hierarchical
structure and so far the answer is we're
going to have a negative result we
actually had an RSS paper this summer
with knuckle Golfland is not an
assistant professor at Arizona State
University
and the paper was actually titled
negative results and lfd people in
reinforcement learning try to break down
problems this is some of like Knuckles
earlier work where you're wanting to
look at trajectory segmentation or other
ways of breaking up individual motor
Primitives and then hierarchically
composing them and then also people in
cognitive science have tried to
understand how we do this as well
I want I'm going to be specific when I
talk about abstractions for say cooking
and yes that does say manure because we
weren't going to use real food and
that's not real manure it's just pretend
manure because we're going to create
potting mixtures degree create the right
like acidity or whatever for the soil
that you want for the for the exotic
plant that you're going to grow so this
is what I mean you're not going to want
to demonstrate the entire task for a
robot you're going to want to break it
up and then you're going to want to
break it up it's such a granular level
that each little primitive can have some
generalizability and can be composed in
this hierarchical fashion and we
developed an abstraction score that was
kind of shown
um qualitatively on the previous slide
that looks at these different
trajectories and if you run them through
Dynamic movement Primitives or other
learning algorithms that they really
break down unless you actually get the
abstraction hierarchy correct
so we ask do people naturally teach with
abstractions what factors or inducements
might elicit the abstraction-based
teaching and can you then be taught to
give those abstractions we did two
experiments first 28 participants we had
a baseline which somebody shows up
here's the user interface teach the
robot how to mix these different
elements into your soil for a given
recipe on a day and then we said okay
how about for three different days
you're going to come up with three
different mixtures and then here you're
going to come up with like 10 different
mixers but they're all the same
are you going to realize that you can
actually do something like copy paste or
functional programming through your
demonstrations and then finally we're
going to just literally have written
instructions for you and then actually
none of that worked except for the
written instructions and so we said what
else could we do let's still have our
Baseline and a second experiment and
then in one setting we're going to have
people teach with abstractions have the
robot in a Wizard of Oz way show you
what the robot would have done with that
abstraction so it's going to show you
the failure mode that corresponds to the
way you taught can you learn from that
failure mode to improve
or can we show you the answer for a
different task and have you generalize
that to the original task at hand
and so first no most people don't
provide abstractions let alone
sufficient abstractions
second
if we try to induce people by giving
them a ridiculous number of times that
they have to repeat teaching the same
things most people still don't actually
resort to using abstractions or figure
out the sufficient abstraction that they
might use and multitask settings also
don't seem to do this
and then third debug demo maybe helps
some people but actually for a lot of
people we found that they were so
confused by seeing the robot fail that
it made them worse at teaching the
abstraction
um the analog video also seemed to not
help so people were having a hard time
translating the knowledge from teaching
in once in one task to another and it
wasn't until they saw an expert do the
abstraction teaching that they were able
to get it
and so participants do not naturally use
these abstractions contrary to some
indications from prior work and even
when they do they may not be the correct
abstractions that the only medium that
really helped was actually showing the
answer to the person and there's a
diversity Equity inclusion problem I
think I want to call out is that we had
a proxy IQ metric so we're not certified
psychologists who can actually do an IQ
test but there's an online psychometrics
project where they're trying to develop
something that's a proxy for an IQ test
that we administered after the
experiment and we have found that the
abstraction scores that people provide
in their demonstration was higher was
correlated with your IQ
and so we actually got pushback from uh
some people in the HRI Community
saying that perhaps you shouldn't be
looking at that that's a concerning
finding and
um so we actually published it a sid in
RSS
and kind of my position on this is is
actually like if this is a real thing
this is impacting uh the ability to have
everyone benefit from robots and so if
it is a real phenomena we need to note
that it exists and then figure out what
is the right user interface or training
methods so that everyone regardless of
your IQ or this proxy of basically
puzzle solving can benefit from this
technology
um and ultimately hopefully we're going
to be so Aaron headlon and Nina Mormon
have already done studies with user
populations looking at Learning in the
home
with real people as part of the
cognitive empowerment program in Emory
University
Works under peer review so sometime
later I'll be helping her with with
rebuttals so that'll be fun
um
so
how do we close the loop I've shared
with you a little bit in a reciprocal
mind melt how that might work
but I'm going to now talk about
explainable artificial intelligence uh
briefly as I somewhat come to a close in
my talk that another facet of learning
from demonstration is that we don't just
have heterogeneity or sub-optimality we
also have diversity in the way people
like things done not just preferences
but also different heuristics that we
adopt uh work three decades ago tried to
get commercial line Pilots to provide
data for the same flight plan and use a
decision tree to come up with an
autopilot based upon that data and the
commercial line pilot so disagreed in
the way to execute that flight plan that
they found it was better to train a
decision treat on just one Pilot's data
than lumping it together that's not a
scalable approach
in a recent so we recently got an NIH
r01 Grant working with cardiac
profusionists at the VA and at the
Harvard Medical School and we had some
data that we got from them
and I was actually doing this analysis
myself
and what you'll see here is is our model
uh what's this ID thing
I literally put the ID of the row in the
Excel spreadsheet that we got for the
tabular data for how a perfusionist
would decide how to like oxygenate and
keep the flow of your blood properly so
that you don't die during open heart
surgery we see the our accuracy in
predicting what the perfusionist would
do we got like a seven percent jump in
performance just by putting the row ID
in the model and it's like what
why should that matter well I had a
hunch that it might matter and I I asked
our perfusionist partners about this and
they said I said
did you get this data from multiple
different people they're like yeah how
do you know I'm like because they're
different
they think differently and they're at
the same institution practicing together
if you don't account for this not only
do you get a hit but you also have to
realize that there's not necessarily a
gold standard and Care there's
definitely not a gold standard in a lot
of healthcare domains people are doing
their best and they're very smart
but we have a long way to go before we
can write down an actual reward function
that says here is the knob setting I
need here so that you die 70 years from
now a very happy person
connecting that is really really
difficult
but on the way to get there I want to at
least be able to learn from
heterogeneity and so either I can learn
a model for each individual perfusionist
or I can cluster them and then learn
within each cluster of perfusionists and
pool their data to help fight the
conversive dimensionality to be more
data efficient but the objective for
clustering and the objective for inverse
reinforcement learning are different
objectives and so the cluster you the
cluster you get might not actually be
good for IRL but what if you could do
variational inference and learn in some
embedding space the way in which
everyone each individual person is
different from the typical or or
prototypical or maximally Bland decision
maker
um to be able to tease this out
and how can we explain then to the
perfusionist why the model is right or
what it's learned about you this is uh
Brad Hayes's joke from
um Colorado why did the neural network
cross the road
I don't know but look it did really well
a lot of people that's all they care
about but every time I go to the Navy to
Health Care they like want their linear
regression a decision tree scares them
so we're a long way from having these
neural networks to actually gain support
of these practitioners and so we
developed personalized neural trees
which are it's basically a fuzzy tree so
we replace the decision nodes of each in
the tree with a sigmoid to get a degree
of Truth and then we can have the leaves
be a probably distribution over actions
or labels then we can do back prop over
this
we're going to have an embedding Vector
that characterizes your heterogeneity
and then we're also going to have this
uh PSI C
um for uh Lester Sue and I were talking
earlier about Greek so I need to I think
brush up on my pronunciation uh to be
able to if you can regularize those
feature selector terms then you can
actually get out an exact Boolean tree
at the end of the day so you can
literally tell somebody here here's how
you simulate what I think about your
decision making
and the heterogeneity matters because if
you lump this data together if people
like to pass on the left people pass on
the right if you're not careful and you
average it you're going to crash in the
car in front of you
so
we employ these variational techniques
to be able to tease out the person's
specific components of the variance
extract out the decision three through
our regularization process and when we
evaluated that on a set of planning and
decision-making tasks we found that our
method was able to outperform Prior work
that looked at clustering or not and for
example infogail I think there's
something very special about the neural
tree architecture that's available for
planning and scheduling type tasks and
then when we regularize it we also are
still outperforming many of the
non-interpretable baselines except for
one example when we actually found it
was better to take our model extract
State action pairs from the rollout and
the embeddings we learned and then to
separately train a supervised learning
algorithm or card C 4.5 4.5 to get a
decision tree but in general I don't
think that's a good approach
I'm going to argue that you need to
optimize the interpretable
representation itself let's say we have
a deep reinforcement learning algorithm
trained on carpool many of you might
have done this in this room
you're going to get State action pairs
that are kind of the rollouts of the
neural network executing this task
and then I'm going to take that batch
data set offline and train a decision
tree to mimic the neural network if I do
that and then I use that decision tree
to control the cart pull it will suck
horribly because of the covaria shift
issues that we get in Behavior cloning
instead if you actually directly do back
prop over the neural net over the
decision tree the differentiable form
with the regularization not only do you
get a interpretable representation of
your policy it's also High performing as
a policy itself so you need to learn
align the explainable model itself with
the optimization that you're trying to
perform
but as xai actually useful subjectively
and objectively particularly because so
many people are really interested in
this and so very briefly we have a
journal paper that just came out where
we looked at various forms of
explanation and a common sense reasoning
task looking at posing say Mark has just
started running and is trying to train
for a local Marathon the marathon is set
to take place in a month so Mark has
been training very hard unfortunately a
week before the marathon Mark suffered
an injury what did he injure
this elbow neck knee or back
a robot can offer suggestions provides
some explanation according to one of
these formats and we can measure whether
or not you accept the robot's advice or
reject it and then how much you agree
with it and we found that the right form
of explainability it's not that one form
of explainability fits everyone but if
you look at the subjective rating of
explainability we get from subjects and
then how many answers that they get
correctly there is a weak but Sicily
significant correlation between
explainability and correct decision
making when working with robotic
decision support which is very promising
for the use of this we've also looked at
explainability in human machine teaming
in a neurops paper by Rohan paleja we
had in Minecraft a human and AI agent
work together to collaboratively build a
house
who looked at Micah inslee's three
levels of situational awareness and how
explainable AI May enhance that and we
found that using a situational awareness
Global assessment technique where you
blank out the screen and then ask people
what was happening and what will happen
in the future that for level two
comprehension of the current state of
the environment in level three being
able to project into the future having
full decision trees improves your
situational awareness that's great if
you're wanting to team with an agent
that you've never worked with before but
if you're actually having to spend all
that time reading the decision tree
while trying to play the game
you actually lose performance and so we
argue that explainable AI can help build
shared mental models quickly in ad hoc
teaming settings before you then go in
team and then hopefully you can then use
what you've learned kind of in the
briefing room before you go and play
then how the system will work I like to
point you um to a paper by Mariah Shrum
we have a journal paper coming out
version of this we take trying to
improve the rigor of HRI we take that
seriously and with particularly the
design of subjective questionnaires
there's a lot of
sub-optimal practices that we'd like to
kind of try to address in our community
and if you want to ever get into that
research I'll point you to that paper
basically you see so much red because
that's a quantification of all the bad
unfortunately across the last four years
I'm going to tease that we do a lot of
work in coordinated reasoning for
manufacturing particularly for learning
from people learning models of people as
they get better at the tasks that
they're doing in seasonal manufacturing
and gig economies this is very important
it takes six months for a person or for
a manufacturing line to get fully up to
speed and so we've been looking at
characterizing the learning curves of
individuals working within a human
machine team so that a robot can then
figure out how to explore or exploit
your competencies within us planning
task planning and scheduling framework
and showing that actually people like
the more exploration the robot does to
learn what they're best at
and
um
more work there and with that I think
humans are amazing
and I would be happy to take any
questions as I tease the cool new thing
that I will do in the future
thank you
[Applause]
when you were teaching people uh you
were seeing whether they use
abstractions while teaching how did you
convince them that the robot could
actually deal with
being taught using abstractions how did
we uh it's the question how did we
convince people that the robot could be
taught with abstractions yes how did you
give them the idea that that was even
something that they could be doing and
that the robot would get it yeah we had
to very carefully think about how do we
not just give people the answer but
still give them the opportunity to
figure it out and because some people
did figure it out on their own we think
that the interface was at least
sufficient to afford that so we try to
build in affordances into our graphic
user interface that would allow people
so you could see here's like the recipes
that you could make you could copy paste
them and reuse them in different ways
across different days to do different
things and some people just chose not to
take advantage of that even though we
did provide a training video that showed
the basic functionality of the interface
some people just really wanted to teach
the whole thing end to end
thanks any other questions
it was interesting to see that you know
you clearly saw different strategies
that people took when solving tasks what
do you think is a problem do we lack
representational capacities in our RL
policies that kind of fail to to learn
it or is it the learning process itself
that causes the collapse and actually
the representational capacity is fine as
long as the learning process like could
have accommodated that because of course
we have we see this recurring like many
many times and actually it would be
beneficial to have a policy that could
actually you know go into one mode or
the other mode because maybe something
in the environment changes slightly and
makes one of the you know behaviors more
more appropriate for a particular
environment and so you showed that we
even maybe have it in the human data but
we kind of like are really struggling to
make use of it yeah are you talking
about this work uh yeah but I mean in
general like when you showed clustering
all that stuff right like it's very
clear that it would be nice to be able
to you know instead of it's basically
collapsing to the mean because you have
you know like taking taking a mean of
all this data right and clearly
something is difficult is it that the
policies that we you know tend to you
know like I mean mostly of them are
gaussians and maybe they lack ability to
sort of like be able to be conditioned
on something and pick one mode versus
the other mode or is it the training
procedure itself that is making it
difficult to train in such a way that
you would have this multimodal policy
that can switch depending on yeah so
people are in RL are also looking at
this multi-modati so the question being
like why is this happening why do we
have to explicitly address it there's a
few issues one that there's a latent
variable
that we're not accounting for in our
state space in this case I'm saying it's
some person-specific Factor and so I'm
going to try to infer that from your Ops
your demonstrations so that I can
explain how in the same state two
different people are are doing different
things a neural networks can't figure
that out unless it has some capacity to
reason about a latent variable the other
one is that neural networks are lazy and
with the regularization techniques we do
they're going to overfit to the most
common thing and just prioritize that in
mode collapse so I say it's very similar
to the the problems that people have in
Gans with mode collapse uh inherently
and then also explicitly that there's
latent variables that we're trying to
tease out
and if it's okay can I get in one last
question or we have to get kicked out
okay maybe we might be out of time okay
so all right we'll end here please come
up and if you have additional questions
for Matthew go ahead and ask him and
thanks again for the great talking yeah
thank you
[Applause]